few issues divide the EU more than
migration to its heart like the
questions of who should look after the
people who claim asylum in the block and
what to do with those whose claims fail
for years those countries when most
people arrive have called for help from
other member states but many have not
wanted to help and with more than eighty
thousand Asylum Seekers arriving so far
this year the pressure has grown so the
Swedish presidency of the EU and
European commission have suggested a
two-part deal which they hope will help
border countries with the rising number
of Asylum Seekers arriving and limit
those migrants ability then to move
without permission inside the EU there
is also a spirit of cooperation and
solidarity between member states and
this is worth so much because that means
and we show it also when we actually
activated a temporary protection
directive when we are in this Spirit
where we trust each our we are so strong
in effect the proposal would see member
states that don't want to host more
irregular migrants paying other member
states to host them it's estimated of
five figures some per migrant has been
discussed even then some Eastern
European countries have been skeptical
but the risks of not reaching a deal
were spelled out by the German
government
which itself was in two minds about the
deals and
fighting to ensure that we have a Europe
of open borders if we fail that's the
wrong signal this would lead to National
isolation I don't want to do that I want
to keep the borders open I would like us
to have a common European understanding
of Human Rights standards including at
all external borders Germany already
operates controls on some of its borders
notably with Austria and with Poland as
here where the order river forms the
natural Frontier some European
governments are wary of extending this
policy further and hope what's been
proposed by the EU Council will prevent
that Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Luxembourg